hi uh I will talk about this paper
eventually private continue releases of
streaming frequency moment estimations
uh it's a joint work with El Centro
Andres bahad Sergey and Palin
we're all from Google
let me start with a motivating example
Chrome has an initiative called a
privacy sandbox which develops apis to
reduce cross-site tracking while
supporting the digital advertising
ecosystem
one main component of it is The Flash K
anonymity server which calls for key
anonymity on several features
for example
to avoid micro targeting the server
wants to guarantee that a user won't be
shown an ad
unless some minimum number K of other
users are also shown the same ad
the underlying computation problem for
the server is just to count the number
of the same elements over a sliding
window
uh here we also want the output of the
server to be differentially private
uh since we don't want additional
private information leads to other
parties involved in the ad auctions for
example content Publishers advertisers
and supply side platforms who work with
publishers
here's the actual model considered in
this paper
uh it's kind of summarizing the title
already
uh we could we consider the continual
release setting in which there are t
rounds
in each round we get input 80
and we need to Output the function uh
inputs received so far
um the sliding window setting is a
special case
of the continue release setting in which
the function only depends on inputs from
last W rounds
for a particular function the sliding
window setting could be more difficult
since you need to handle a deletion
the whole talk will mostly focus on the
normal continual release setting and in
the end we will talk about how to
convert a continual release setting
continue continue release algorithm into
a sliding window algorithm
based on some technique from plywood
the function we want to compute in this
paper is the frequency moment
uh here we Define frequency F A as a
number of appearances of a in the Stream
and the lp frequency moment is just a
sum over
non-empty element a
F A to the power of P
for example l0 frequency moment is just
counting the number of distinct elements
mentioning the motivating sample
and L1 frequency moment is just counting
the number of non-empty elements or in
other words the sum of uh binary numbers
well some we consider some general
setting which numbers don't need to be
binary
um we also want the algorithm to be
streaming meaning it is a single path
through the string using small space sub
linear NT
finally we want the whole output over T
rounds to be differentially private
informally it means that if we change
one element in the Stream the output
distribution should not change by much
and in this paper all our algorithms are
pure DP
here's our main result we have a DP
algorithm for LP frequency moment
estimation
um with probability 0.9 it has this uh
approximation guarantee over all T
rounds
the first term in the approximation is
the multiplicative approximation Factor
and the second term is the additive
approximation guarantee
the algorithm uses Holy Love t space
and it is talked with accounting space
in terms of Words which omit the factor
caused by the number of bits for
recording some function value
in the rest of the talk I talk about the
main idea for getting this algorithm
I will start with some special cases of
LP frequency movement estimation and
there are also building blocks of our
main result
the first algorithm I want to talk about
is the binary tree mechanism from prior
work
which also initiated the study of
international privacy in a continued
resetting
uh the algorithm is for computing the
sum
and it only has additive errors
the error is poly log T and this is much
better than some naive approach which
could have error linear in t
the main idea of the algorithm is to
build a binary segment tree
and for each three node release the sum
of inputs from each segment
with some noise for privacy
the guarantee of the algorithm mainly
comes from two nice properties of the
segment tree
first any previous sum can be
represented by the sum of log T three
nodes
and second the input of each run is
included in Atmos log T3 nodes
also one can show that only all of log T
three nodes need to be maintained during
the streaming algorithm
so this algorithm only uses space
overclock t
in this work we also have a new
algorithm called grouping for computing
the cell
compared with the previous algorithm
it has better additive error and uses
smaller space
the drawback of this algorithm is that
first it requires numbers to be
non-negative
and second it has multiplicative errors
this second drawback might be less of a
problem when the algorithm is is used as
a component for some other problem in
which multiplicity multiplicative errors
are unavoidable
the main idea to algorithm is the
following if the numbers we're getting
all rounds are large enough much bigger
than the noise
we can simply add noise to each number
and output the sum of noisy numbers
this will just give us some
multiplicative error
however in general we may get some small
numbers in some rounds
to deal with these small numbers
the algorithm groups consecutive rounds
to make sure that the sum of each group
is large enough
um notice that we also need to generate
this grouping private View and for that
we will use an algorithm called above
thresholds from prior word which I don't
have time to go over
another thing I want to mention here is
that a similar idea has been used in
Prior work for getting better additive
error if the streams are sparse
next we consider distinct elements
we start with uh the easy case when
elements are from a small universe
in this case we can keep a set of
appearing Elements
by using some small space
and we generate a modified stream
in which a t is changed to empty if it
has appeared before round t
the number of distinct elements in the
original string is just the number of
non non-empty elements in the modify
stream
so we can use the DP algorithm for some
on the modified screen and we have
reduced uh the distinct elements problem
to solve
uh there's one more subtlety we need to
make sure in this reduction is that for
two neighboring streams
we want to make sure that the
corresponding modified streams don't
differ by too much
actually we can show the only difference
at cause and many loans
um also notice that this idea would work
when we have no space constraint even if
the universe is big actually when there
are no specific constraints there are
more General results which include
distinct elements from plywood
for the case with a large Universe we
will try to reduce the problem to the
case with a small universe
the main idea here is to use sampling
and hashing
we create a modify screen in which each
sample elements
is changed to its hash value
and now the modify stream has a small
universe
and we can use the algorithm from the
previous slides to count the number of
distinct elements in this modified
screen
we try different setting risks in
parallel and find the smallest sampling
rate such that the number of these
distinct elements of the modify screen
is still large enough
we estimate the number of distinct
elements of the original string as a
number of distinct elements of the
modified string divided by the segment
rate
this is a good estimation since we can
show that there's no collisions between
sampled elements with good probability
if we use this particular sampling rate
finally we are ready to look at the
general frequency moment estimation
problem
for low frequency elements we will use a
similar strategy as how we calculating
elements
we start by considering the case with a
small universe
in this case we can maintain a set of
elements for each low frequency I
um
we call this that s i
from SI we can count its size CI
uh notice that as a new round each CI is
changed by Atmos one
and therefore we can view CI as a sum of
plus minus ones and zeros
so we can release a Ci's privately using
the binary tree mechanism
again for this to work we need to make
sure that neighboring streams have not
very different CIS
um so this gives a algorithm for a
the small universe
now for the case with a large universe
we use a similar sampling idea from the
previous slides to reduce it to the case
with a small units
for high frequency elements we use a
different technique from heavy heaters
um the lp heavy heaters are defined as
elements whose frequencies to the power
of P
are greater than 1 over K times the lp
frequency moment of the Stream
for some parameter k
we first find L2 heavy heaters using car
sketch
it it hashes elements into K buckets and
assigns each element's a random sign
for each bucket it computes v i as a sum
of frequencies weighted by the random
signs for elements in the bucket
the main idea here is that
if a bucket has only one high frequency
element together with a bunch of low
frequency elements
um
the absolute value of CI can be used to
estimate the frequency of the high
frequency element as a low frequency
elements contribution to GI canceled out
mostly due to the random signs
again notice that here z i is a sum of
plus minus one and we can release it
privately using the binary trim
mechanism
for General LP heavy heaters we can use
a single reduction from prior work to
reduce it to the L2 having Heat
to put things together
uh we use a level set argument from
prior work to partition elements into
sets of different frequency levels
and estimate the set sizes
for small I
corresponding to
low frequency elements
we will just use accounts of low
frequencies low frequency Elements which
we discussed two slides ago
uh and for large I it can be shown that
there exists some sampling rate such
that all sampled elements from AI are
heavy heaters
with good probability
and we can use uh
the heavy heaters techniques from the
previous slides of the subsample stream
to estimate the size of II
um so far this talk has been focusing on
normal continue release algorithms uh
which computes functions based on all
historical inputs
and in this slides I want to briefly
mention that
they can be turned into sliding window
algorithms using a technique called
Smooth isograph developing prior work
the sliding window setting might be more
relevant for many practical applications
the smooth histogram technique is
basically the following
uh Cosmos functions
they show that a low space continue
released algorithm can be turned into a
sliding window algorithm with not much
worse multiplicative approximation
guarantee and space
when we apply this most histogram
technique to our algorithms in this work
we also adjust the analysis a little bit
to deal with algorithms which have both
additive and multiplicative errors
and we also make sure that the DP
guarantees don't get much worse
that's all I have thanks for listening